[Music]
welcome back family and individual open
enrollment period it's happening now
through january 15th and select health
who is sponsoring this segment will be
hosting a phone bank tomorrow here to
give us a preview is sebastian and greg
from the select health answer team
welcome guys good day how are you doing
good to see you guys what is the number
one question you get asked about open
enrollment boy it has to be deadlines
deadlines and and the process what is
needed for the process and here in
nevada january 15th is our deadline to
have an effective date of february 1st
so need to know that and the ways you
can do that is by asking questions to us
tomorrow we'll be happy to answer those
questions you have selecthealth.org and
you have the nevada health link that can
help you get the the services that you
need for your health insurance
enrollment so that is workforce we have
the phone bank and both you gentlemen
other staff members will be back there
and anyone has any kind of questions
they can call and you'll answer them
that's perfect we're the answer team
that's right that's why you're answering
so let's talk about more i was reading
that you guys have tax credits tell us
more about the tax credits yeah
absolutely one of the things that a lot
of families maybe didn't qualify for
before so we want them to remember that
they may qualify for 2022 is a subsidy
so help to pay for the premium for the
health insurance and a lot of families
also may qualify for a reduction on
their co-pays deductibles and
co-insurance so there's a lot of help
out there to help subsidize you know the
cost of health care and a lot of
families again that maybe in the past
had a small subsidy or no subsidy may
qualify now for one so we want everybody
to give it a chance and go to uh our
website give us a call or listen to to
our you know presentation tomorrow now
also i was reading to you guys do a lot
when it comes to gym memberships
it's all about health we want to promote
health and good health in 2022 what are
some of the discounts and stuff that you
guys offer well there's there's there's
several and if you're an individual and
you you become a member for 240 dollars
it can be put towards a gym membership
that's great and if you're a family it'd
be 580
and if if there's certain certain uh
plans that we have if you've taken 7 000
steps a day we can also help you out
that way everyone's looking right now
checking their phone to see how many
steps they did today i don't think i'm
at the 7000 mark that is great something
else too uh share reductions what are
shared reductions well that's exactly
you know uh what a lot of people have in
mind which is when you purchase a health
plan is i have a deductible that i have
to cover before the insurance will kick
in i have a 20 or 30 percent of the cost
once you once i use medical services so
the share reduction means that a lot of
families may qualify to reviews that
co-pay to zero that deductible maybe to
zero and that 30 or 20 percent to a
lower co insurance so that will help you
with your cost when you use your medical
services and this phone bank tomorrow
it's great someone's watching right now
married single they got a family they
have some questions you guys are gonna
have the answers and you'll spend time
with them too it's not a quick answer
someone has a bunch of questions you'll
answer all of them but let's let's take
care of all your questions uh the
deadline's the 15th we're here to help
everyone out uh we have a facebook live
also yeah happening too so we want to be
available and we want to make all those
questions uh become reality so you can
be insured i love it gentlemen thank you
so much tomorrow is go time for you guys
we'll see you back here at the station
we appreciate it thank you you can call
the eight uh channel light phone bank
with live select health answer team
tomorrow from three to seven
select health are the sponsors of this
segment and they're located at 1960
festival plaza suite 9 30. for more
information go to select health dot org
in las vegas